a man of many talents Tom Bergeron APU
the time jakka on the masked singer
[Music]
[Applause]
can we talk about the taco why a taco
well I was the last person cast in Group
B and by that point they only had two
choices
obviously a taco costume the other one
was a jellyfish yeah so I think I picked
the right one the taco was a good call
yeah it's much more entertaining than
watching something that you think might
sting you was it hard to get the taco
that tomato mask on and off the tomato
mask was the easiest part the hardest
part was the hard shell taco itself I
had to get in one side and then that
goes around and you're in there and and
I the second number I did was bossa nova
baby and help us Presley no way and try
shaking your hips in a taco shell it
ain't happening they just give you a new
special love and affection for tacos
yeah I've always been very fond of tacos
this in out of respect for my trainer
was a vegan taco but yeah yeah I'll
never eat one quite the same no you'll
never eat a taco quite the same again
will you that's like family now the
tacos are family to you ah some
contestants have done a good job of
keeping the secret some of struggle yeah
was it hard for you to keep the secret
no and I'll give you some backstory when
my wife was pregnant with our first
daughter years ago I wanted to find out
the sex of the baby at the ultrasound
and she didn't right so I knew for six
months for the second and third
trimester we were having a girl and I
kept that secret from from your wife if
you can keep secrets from your wife
you can keep secrets from that any body
I mean anybody all right what about your
Dancing with the Stars family what was
their reaction to seeing you well sand
and that's it that's a great question
because that was really largely the
reason I did it a lot of the the
production staff of masked singer are
alums of Dancing with the Stars right so
for me it was like a hidden homecoming
and they do the show on the very same
soundstage
the starts jenny has my dressing room so
I almost wanted to see if my security
badge work still yeah so like any get
out yeah get out i plunge so it was
great and it was great largely because i
posted a picture on my twitter page of
the reunion of all the dancing people
alums on stage with me and now that you
are an alum of the mass singer could we
see any of the judges on the show or
anyone else well that's up to them but i
certainly i certainly have popped the
cherry
you said it now i all right
um now that your secret has been
revealed let's have some fun and talk
about some secrets about you I'm gonna
blow all right real quick okay you don't
like watching yourself on TV no that's
true I've uh you've only watch yourself
once once on Dancing with the Stars we
gathered in my dressing room back in
2005 to watch the West Coast feed of the
first show we did AFV which I hosted for
15 yes maybe I've seen a half a dozen
mostly because I you if we do it what
bothers you about I knew I'm I think I'm
I'm very uncomfortable watching myself
on TV right and you hear a lot of actors
say that too they don't like watching I
love doing it doing it up I love but
yeah I don't watch myself alright that's
interesting
um you are pretty ripped by the way I
don't know if you guys have seen this
but I mean Tom Bergeron is ripped that
was like tour oh there you go angry
workout man that that was the the cheeky
thing they put in the in the package the
clues a washboard you know it was like
them goofing on me working out all the
time how often are you working out every
day what were five days a week
Wow and then I hike on weekends you you
hike on week do yoga too right yeah but
not as you know I meditate I do TM
meditations on that forever Tom don't
have people out here meditating thinking
they were to get ripped okay you're not
gonna get no you know yeah and
meditation is not a big calorie burn no
not not at all
alright what's the one secret did you
have about working out the one secret
what secret system see it really is new
or get no results yeah yeah you can't
dance but there is one thing that will
get you on the dance floor yeah
tequila I mean that's everybody right
yeah but you will dance with a little
tequila I did a dance season two when we
did result shows I did a the world's
slowest quick step cuz I wanted to see
what it was like yeah
and that was enough that was good little
Tiki lien I did I'll it's not yes I was
sadly sober that night you were sad okay
because I also had to co-host the show
in addition to dancing on it all right
before you go can you give us because we
heard the songs you song on the show but
what's your go-to karaoke song which
you're so well I will say this I had
written alternate lyrics for Candyman
hoping I could sing that
what would your automate Liron we
couldn't get the clearance but I'll do
something for you right now mm-hmm
come on who can make the Sun Rise
sprinkle it with Dew add a little salsa
and a jalapeno to the taco man the taco
man can yeah yeah the taco man yeah yeah
Tom yeah where as you will be known
forever as the taco man thank you for
being here
[Music]